this car goes 250 miles per hour this
train goes 350 miles per hour and this
plane goes 550 miles per hour and those
are all slower than this bullet which
travels at 800 miles per hour but this
new plane from boom supersonic goes over
1 000 miles per hour and there's a good
chance it could change how we travel
forever the only faster way to get
around might be using a spacex rocket
but elon's plan for that is still
completely untested now supersonic
planes have been around since the 1960s
but we'll get into the history of high
speed travel a bit later first we need
to talk about the founder of boom
supersonic blake shoal is on a mission
to bring supersonic travel to the masses
and he's making solid progress imagine
new york to london in three and a half
hours for about the same fair you paid
in business class today in just five
years he's raised hundreds of millions
of dollars hired dozens of engineers and
built a working prototype called xb1
that can travel at mach 2.2 but the most
impressive part is that he had zero
experience in the aerospace industry so
how'd he do it
even though blake doesn't have an
aerospace background he's an engineer by
training he studied computer science in
college and then went to work for amazon
all the way back in 2001. while there he
built an automated system that would buy
google ads for amazon products that
turned into a 300 million dollar p l by
the time i was 24. joining a high growth
startup like amazon in the early days is
one of the best ways to accelerate your
career no big company would hire a 24
year old to manage a 300 million dollar
piece of their business but by joining a
risky venture blake was able to develop
management skills that help make boom a
reality later on after a few years at
amazon blake wanted to start his own
company so he launched an app called
barcode hero i'm blake shull i'm the
co-founder and ceo of barcode hero
barcode hero lets you zap a product
barcode with your phone to find a
competitor's pricing share thoughts or
recommendations the app received
positive reviews and was growing
steadily but mobile commerce was an
extremely competitive market back in
2010. it's now extremely common for
startups to spend years completely
focused on building a great product
before trying to make money but back
then questions about profitability
popped up much earlier can you tell me
though how far along you need to be
before you start to make a profit to be
honest we're a ways away from that our
business model is to create a shopping
application that people want to use when
they're in a store to help them make
better decisions about what to buy so in
2012 groupon acquired blake's company
for an undisclosed sum and shut down
barcode hero it doesn't look like it was
an amazing outcome but blake clearly
wasn't deterred he wanted to go bigger
with his next startup so he set his
sights higher literally
blake had been flying planes since he
was in college and always dreamt of
having a real impact on the aviation
industry he didn't have the perfect
resume to start a company that builds
airplanes but that didn't bother him
after all the wright brothers had only
built bicycles before they made the
first airplane and elon musk was running
a payments company before launching
spacex so blake founded boom supersonic
and began building a team around the
idea of safe and sustainable high-speed
travel one of the first major milestones
for the company was joining the startup
accelerator y combinator although yc is
typically known for funding software
startups like airbnb stripe and coinbase
the partners at y combinator love all
ambitious entrepreneurs building
physical things though is usually much
harder than writing software there are
long research and development cycles
expensive manufacturing bills and plenty
of regulatory hurdles but blake
developed a really interesting method
for overcoming these challenges at boom
we believe that life happens in person
and that real face time
beats facetime blake is obsessed with
the idea that in-person interactions are
inherently more valuable than
conversations over the phone or email
and he really lives this mantra why
combinator's demo day was quickly
approaching and blake was going to have
to present boom to a huge group of
investors he needed to demonstrate that
airlines would actually buy the
supersonic planes he was going to build
emails and phone calls to airlines were
going nowhere so he decided to hop on a
plane and get some face time with
richard branson virgin galactic was
rolling out a new spaceship and blake
knew that this was an incredible
opportunity we ended up we ended up
crashing the rollout i never actually
got my name on the invite list but we've
got our 15 minutes with richard branson
we're not asking you to invest in the
company uh we're asking when the
airplane is delivered whether you'd like
to have the first few with a virgin logo
on the tail this was a huge moment for
the company everyone knows richard
branson and virgin airlines so overnight
boom became much more legitimate in the
eyes of investors most importantly
virgin didn't actually have to spend any
money up front so it was easy to get the
deal approved i was actually at the yc
demo day where blake first presented
boom to investors and the reaction was
pretty amazing everyone loved the idea
and couldn't wait to invest none of the
specifications of the airplane had been
decided yet after all the company was
still brand new but blake had a clear
vision for what would be most important
to airlines speed safety and
sustainability these might seem like
vague marketing terms but they are
actually extremely calculated based on
the previous failures of supersonic
development in order to understand why
blake is so focused on these particular
values we have to go back to 1969.
america had just landed a man on the
moon and the first commercial supersonic
airplane was about to take flight it was
the concorde and it had a lot in common
with boom's new aircraft on the concorde
a trip from new york to london took just
over three hours and it felt like the
dawn of an entirely new age throughout
human history increases in the speed of
transport have had remarkable second
order effects in the 1840s crossing the
united states required traveling in a
covered wagon the journey took months
and people often died in transit but in
1869 the transcontinental railroad
shortened that trip to just 83 hours
america went through a remarkable period
of growth as people migrated westward
and in the 1930s transcontinental
airlines began moving americans across
the country in just 20 hours a few
decades later jet engines cut that time
down to just six hours and travel
exploded the jet age affected culture in
remarkable ways the beatles were able to
go on the first world tour and become an
international sensation and major league
baseball became a national sport played
all over the united states not just in
the northeast it's always hard to
predict the effects of faster travel but
throughout history great things always
happen when we start moving faster the
concorde promised to make international
travel dramatically more accessible but
there were still a ton of problems and
most of them came back to speed safety
and sustainability speed was obviously
the main selling point of the concord
business travelers value their time
extremely highly and are willing to pay
lots of money to save time but it's also
just cool to go fast and celebrities
loved how fast the concorde went
it's always exciting flying supersonic
and it's always exciting to get to new
york before you've left but traveling at
mach 2 can cause some real issues the
first of which was heat the concorde
went so fast that the plane would heat
up substantially the entire fuselage had
to be coated in a highly reflective
white paint in order to deflect as much
light as possible one concord was
painted blue during a promotion for
pepsi and wound up only being able to
stay at mach 2 for 20 minutes because of
the heat buildup the concorde was built
before computer simulation allowed for
engineers to test performance in virtual
environments so a lot of these issues
had to be worked out through painstaking
experiments but boom is building their
planes using the latest software tools
the second issue was fuel you would
expect a plane that goes twice as fast
to use twice as much fuel but the
concord actually used more than five
times as much fuel as modern commercial
airliners this meant that tickets had to
be extremely expensive to offset the
cost of fuel and every trip came with
significant carbon emissions boom is
leveraging advances in engine design
that yield greater fuel efficiency which
will mean cheaper ticket prices but they
aren't stopping there boom plans to use
fuel made from carbon that was removed
from the atmosphere meaning that
supersonic travel will be carbon neutral
from day one increased fuel efficiency
won't just make new york to london trips
more affordable though it will actually
open up entirely new routes the concorde
was never able to fly across the pacific
but boom has planned to offer service
from san francisco to tokyo since day
one these new routes will expand the
market for these planes and give boom a
better chance at winning blake also
thinks about pricing differently than
the executives who ran the concord
project he wants to continually bring
prices down until you can get anywhere
in the world for just a hundred bucks
but the concord executives were much
more focused on short-term profitability
british airways and air france actually
performed market research to inform
their pricing strategy they found that
people generally thought of the concord
as extremely expensive so they raised
their prices to match expectations this
is fine when your customer is a rich
business traveler but if you're catering
to wealthy people you need to have a
perfect safety record and safety is what
really did the concord in news tonight
this tuesday the first concord ever to
crash just after takeoff from paris
113 people are killed which included
everyone on board shortly after the turn
of the millennium air france flight 4590
crashed during takeoff and killed
everyone on board the plane had run over
a piece of debris on the runway and
ruptured a tire it destroyed the
concorde's reputation and grounded the
entire fleet for months one year later
the september 11th terrorist attacks
crushed the entire airline industry and
forced the concorde into early
retirement
but boom is learning from all of this
airplane safety protocols have advanced
significantly in the past two decades
and the problem with the concorde's
tires has been thoroughly investigated
many of the safety issues with the
concorde came from the fact that
engineers on the project had a goal of
delivering a supersonic plane at
essentially any cost the original budget
for the concord was 70 million but the
project wound up costing more than a
billion engineers had to make lots of
compromises to get the concorde to work
one of which was the nose of the
airplane because the plane landed at
such a steep angle the pilots couldn't
see the runway as they approached so the
entire nose cone of the plane would tilt
down during landing boom just installed
the camera in the front of the plane
there's like camera toggle button you
can hit and it flips over and you get
all your flight controls overlaid on top
of what is a virtual window through the
nose of the airplane and so you get you
get better runway visibility than you
get with with a traditional subsonic
cockpit it's such a simple solution that
significantly reduces complexity i love
it another issue that plagued the
concord was the fact that it required a
flight engineer to be on board during
every flight essentially the plane was
so complex that a trained expert had to
sit in the cockpit with the pilots just
to ensure everything went smoothly this
created a ton of extra cost and even
with the flight engineer most airlines
still had to have an extra concorde
sitting on standby at all times this is
because concord passengers were so
demanding that no airline could afford
to frustrate customers with delays if
there were maintenance issues boom is
building for reliability from day one
and by simplifying the design of the
plane and using software solutions
wherever possible they should be able to
avoid many of the pitfalls that the
concord faced lastly there is the issue
of noise the fact that blake named his
company boom is pretty funny since the
sonic boom was one of the major issues
of the concord sonic booms are so
powerful that they can break windows in
houses below and for that reason the
united states has put a speed limit on
aircraft traveling over the country but
nasa engineers are working on solving
the issue of the sonic boom as well it's
unlikely that they'll ever be able to
muffle it entirely but there's a good
chance that they could lower the boom
from 105 decibels to just 70 decibels
and at that volume u.s lawmakers might
revisit the speed limit if it means
getting from california to washington dc
in half the time strict regulation is
just one of the many factors that has
led to stagnation in the aerospace
industry and prominent investors like
peter thiel have been calling for
america to address this for years now i
often think it's worth looking at
quantity not quality and we're not going
faster you know the concorde was
decommissioned in 2003 and if you
include low-tech airport security
mechanisms we're back to about 1960 type
travel speeds uh today in the u.s um
part of the problem with the concord was
that ultimately it was a vanity project
by the uk and french governments they
had amazing engineers working on the
technology but they never had a strong
economic model but boom is thinking of
the business model from day one and they
already have signed contracts with
airlines only 14 concords ever saw
commercial service but united airlines
has already committed to buying 20
planes from boom that's really solid
progress but boom does have some strong
competition regular subsonic planes are
getting faster and more efficient it's
also possible to have a more productive
flight on a traditional plane now that
you can use the wi-fi to get some work
done or sleep in a lay flat seat in
first class there are also other
companies working on developing
supersonic planes like spike aerospace
and arion supersonic although arion
recently went out of business but i
think boom's real competition will come
from outside the traditional airline
industry there are several companies
working on planes capable of vertical
takeoff and landing which could change
the way we travel even if everything is
still subsonic a huge amount of any trip
is spent just getting to and from the
airport and these new vtol aircraft will
make it much easier to get to smaller
airports then their spacex point to
point elon musk thinks he can get
passengers from new york to tokyo in
just 30 minutes using a rocket this is
clearly a long shot but if it works it
would be substantially faster than
flying in a supersonic plane lastly we
can't forget about the exponential
growth of the internet every year
internet speeds get faster and more
people get connected video conferencing
just saw a massive surge in adoption
during the pandemic and people are more
comfortable doing business remotely now
virtual reality is still in its infancy
but facebook is working hard to make
communication in vr indistinguishable
from reality this is all part of a
larger initiative to build what people
are calling a metaverse but that's a
topic for another video thanks for
watching